Hello Internet users
Are you enjoying the Internet session?
You may see this section with lots of open tabs
Full of interesting things.
The Internet is stunning because of the rules governing how it works
The most important of which is "network neutrality"
Treat all data equally.
But some Internet service providers (operators) want to give up this rule
In order to put themselves between you and your data
As one of the most mediating mediators in human history
For their own sake and against our interests.
How do? Well, think of the Internet as a bunch of pipes.
Some of them are pipelines that transcend the oceans and continents and are flooded with enormous rivers of data.
You can not access those pipes directly - because they are too expensive
You can not deal with it anyway.
But you have a small pipe attached to the big pipes
You can get data from them or send them through.
You are paying telecom companies to get this pipeline.
The rule of network neutrality means that the small tube does not care what goes through it:
Funny cats clips
Forums
Calls
Or games.
Whatever you do, you use that tube completely
No site receives preference without the other.
Everyone wants a higher speed Internet, but that needs more conduits in the ground
Which are slowly and expensive to build.
You may have heard telecom companies talk about having this rule
Preventing them from building "highways" for particular types of data
They want you to think they are expanding your access to the information hotline
But removing the base of grid neutrality also gives them power
To put pitfalls in the current roads and impose higher fees for the use of "highway"
Which was as fast as you used to be.
The power to favor some data over others
Is the power to favor a video site over another
And select a very small part of the tube for the section you are watching now
Or trying
that
Whatever the case.
We passed this before: we imposed similar limits on other companies.
For example, take electricity for example
You pay for a certain amount and when you arrive at your place you can do whatever you want.
The electricity company can not decide that instead of building more generators
It will weaken your lamps
Then you provide a monthly subscription for "stronger lights".
The same should apply to the Internet.
Watt electricity is watts of electricity
The kilobut is the kilobut
And we will always need more and more.
Maintaining the network neutrality base of the Internet
It has a much wider impact than just taking a company more of your loans.
I do not want to be too dramatic here
But maintaining data integrity may be one of the most important issues for this generation.
Because without this rule, telecom operators can hinder competitors who do not like them.
Did you notice that the same company that sells you Internet service also sells a subscription to watch TV, fixed line, connections and mobile messages
Things that the Internet completely replaces?
Without data parity, the telecom company can narrow the pipeline to its competitors
So you have to get out of the market, or pay for an intruder or both.
It's like if a shop in the city promises to take care of highways everywhere
As long as the city gave them full power on all roads without retreating.
If you agree to that deal, do not be surprised years later when all the roads leading to that store become
Fast and free while the roads leading to other places are slow and neglected.
This city is in short the Internet without the neutrality of the network
Which will be loved by telecom operators, but actual Internet users will not like it as much.
Making each pipe handle every data the same way allows the owner a good idea
Some knowledge in programming will do something today that millions will see tomorrow.
But only because his data is treated equally with everything else in the pipe.
The Internet treats data equally
It is the Internet that will continue to rain with wonders.
But the Internet in which the mediator to choose and control what goes through it
Internet is the recession for all and profits for little.
That's why some telecom companies will always want to take control
So the cost of maintaining the Internet is wonderful
Is the constant vigilance of righteous citizens to defend the neutrality of the network.
Translation: team translate @autrjim